hey how's it goin Brisbane sorry sorry
we already heard you uh welcome to night
for um Oh God hello hello again great
way to start a video all right so I got
some tips for me brows thank you by the
way first trip spring-trap is really
hard to find in certain cameras
sometimes you only see his legs I agree
he is really hard to find ah so what you
have to do there is I'll play the audio
for you baby
my little baby boo it seems also that
the more you used to [ __ ] the more they
go out also it's my only defense against
him
besides the vent blocks you can avoid
hallucinations by being really fast
someone said if I see it I just have to
make sure I don't get [ __ ] hard and if
I stay on the camera too long foxy will
appear it says and I avoid mangle the
same way as I do with the bubble boy
bubble but I mean and apparently chica
is unavoidable just don't go in the room
Oh God go now there's sanic reflexes
mate
I am so dead now uh there is one thing
know for certain where is he oh my god I
totally lost him areas so I'm supposed
to just look at him and once he leaves
I'll play the audio cuz then he's
supposed to come back he left and I was
back look at that beautiful don't like
it though
you left play the audio [ __ ] back are
[ __ ] in the vents I repeat [ __ ]
are in the vents
oh yes block park okay
oh god I'm dead now aren't I
show me his penis there yes there you
are found you you little [ __ ]
what're you gonna do huh hey left come
back to Papa
Oh God he did not come back at the papa
waiti where did he go
goddamn alright then I guess it doesn't
always work I gotta say though it's not
scary
it's like a horror themed strategy
strategy game at this point
I don't know hey buddy hey misty been
makes you my friend [ __ ] in the vents
[ __ ] in the vents [ __ ] in the
veins pitch it to the bank [ __ ] it's in
the bank which isn't the point which is
in vain gotta go in the vents
don't be a no don't oh god that was
close
oh my god he's gonna [ __ ] me now I
didn't [ __ ] him in time
yeah hey hey buddy had a zit did what
you're behind me Angie it's cute no hey
Joe oh my god this is redonkulous and
there's not even John kids in this game
oh my god they're not working are you
[ __ ] me
Oh Oh in feet away ten out of ten
stop you have to listen to boots he
wants to balloon boys ass that's why he
does it
give me that balloon boy yes that it's a
this a ballon boy
oh man I love balloon boy's ass oh my
god oh my god
Gary Gary I told you to fix the audio
[ __ ] yes yes it's gonna be fine
it's just a spring try there see he's
there oh my god did he just [ __ ] run
past my face what a [ __ ] I don't
understand why why he gives you warning
that a jump scare is coming I appreciate
it we're getting we're getting there
price we can do it we're doing great
this is so good nope you come back here
come back here young man that's right
you're my [ __ ] I'm sorry I'm so sorry
I'm the [ __ ] I got it all wrong
what is this check ah this guy was so
easy up until tonight for you stay there
stay there you [ __ ] [ __ ] again my
god my god there was some work this is
the boy you might as well just [ __ ]
burn this place to the ground all right
nothing works nothing
nothing go away Freddie oh he's still
there
good job I feel like I'm trying to keep
up control of an angry teenager your
rebellious teenager doesn't want to
listen to his daddy come back let's
right stay there [ __ ] my balls hurt
there make it you're giving me blue
balls here man
video games video games video games
video games video games
oh my god video games yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes I know I know Jerry I know
you're a piece of [ __ ] system you better
still be there good girl damn it
come back here
stupid tea what how dare you my blood is
on your hands Jerry we're doing so well
my God where is Jerry no Balloon Boy
aah nope bad bad girl no [ __ ] listen
[ __ ] doesn't listen come back well
watch your room Jerry
spring-trap aah the pictures listen I'm
dead now I'm dead I might work here
myself where is she I don't have time
for this
yes good girl good girl good girl good
girl
sturdy no no stay there yes there your
first bridge Wow German techno press to
victory dance ever
yes I think so thank you thank you very
much hi I'm foxy I'm a fox I have blue
balls curse of this game follow me you
say I'll follow you forever I love you I
love you baby
follow me he said me nope nope no now
what a dick Oh story getting into this
now it's getting young teenager that's
right come back here okay learn [ __ ]
you're such a balloon beep what
everything is [ __ ] now Balloon Boy
everything you [ __ ] it all ray Z now
oh my god the fence sealed you
did it work I don't know man
Oh God he's right outside we're [ __ ]
kill me then
he's so [ __ ] hard to find bubble but
yes
no set him go find my baby go hold the
jack oh damn that was close
speech I could find him at least once
I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know where he
is
oh great
are you are you serious right now Oh
fantastic timing mate I get it you want
to [ __ ] me but not everyone can not
everyone has to privilege 5:00 a.m. but
I'm so [ __ ] I'm gonna die any second I
know it
[ __ ] audio arrow now like Jesus
Christ where is he seriously thank you
sir
so I go back to your hometown [ __ ] come
on like fart my BOB oh I want to be the
very best there's no honor the worst to
catch them is my real test bring the
miss my cows Wow I was born in Sweden
Ireland sorry I get way too excited oh
no all my friends are dead then you go
up here what's he did you hey you
no no no Graham [ __ ] you up
drop [ __ ] you i [ __ ] you up yeah what
you want what do you want you huh
what you gonna do a little bit oh god he
went inside him are you are you are you
spin trap oh my god he's on his menses I
knew it hashtag relatable good times
hey we got the bad ending what
hey are you are you what what what hey
we unlock nightmare and extra all right
Prez I know there is one more mode like
night six and I'll see if I can figure
out how to get the good ending
I think it must have something to do
with that where you go English order I
know some people are so already working
on anyway thank you for watching thank
you for leaving like and in June so if
you want more that way I know and as
always you brothers in the next one say
awesome wow I did it I'm so proud of
myself